[Music]
you know it has been six years since
Whitney Houston's tragic passing and now
a new documentary produced in part by
the Houston family promises the show an
intimate and unflinching portrait of
Whitney that goes beyond the tabloid
headlines
[Music]
she said mommy all I want to do this
thing I said she tell me where she got
grown I stole this magnet started
happening to it she said and that's what
she called it
I didn't ask for all this madness
Whitney's mom's [ __ ] sanctioned the new
documentary full of raw
never-before-seen moments celebrating
the late divas talent and examining the
toll fame took on her personal life she
was sample she became Whitney Houston
when it was time for her to get on stage
she just wanted to escape depression
featuring rare and previously unreleased
recordings the film also shares new
insights from those who were closest to
Whitney including her brother Michael
ex-husband Bobby Brown and her bodyguard
co-star Kevin Costner wasn't just me who
protected there were all the people
around her on bodyguard did you know we
wanted her to do well it was important
for us that she do well anybody loved it
she was a little girl wishing upon a
star I was trying to find my way back
Whitney will premiere at this year's
Cannes Film Festival on May 16
[Music]
[Applause]